everyone a happy Red Dead Redemption to
launch day I am super excited to be
showing you the entire map today because
people when they found out that I had
played the game had been asking me so
much well so often to show them the map
I thought that I would make this video
showing you guys what the map looks like
but then I'm actually going to ride from
the top right corner as far towards the
bottom-left as I can possibly go so I'm
gonna turn my camera and my mic off and
just let it ride but I thought that I
would sort of explain some stuff at the
start here so this is what the full map
looks like to begin with this all up
here is mountains that are so slippery
that if you try to climb on them you
will fall off you will drown if you try
to swim across water here obviously some
parts of the middle I have not covered
up yet but yeah this is pretty much all
of it those those out of boundaries
around here areas you can't go to and it
gets real snowy up the top here down
here I cannot go to so if I try to even
go there I will get shot we'll do that
at the end of the video probably because
right now I'm all the way up here I'll
ride all the way down here and show you
how quickly I die but this is also the
original map this is the map for the
original game so you likely already have
seen it but just for context if I scroll
it's also pretty big so there's a big
blank space here that I just can't get
to yet I suspect that this right here is
also an island that at some point I will
be able to get to but I just haven't
been able to in the story just yet and
died when I tried to swim over there so
when we actually jump into the game I'm
in this beautiful waterfall area up here
at this point of the map actually I will
say it has some interesting stuff going
on you should check it out when you can
but I'm going to turn my microphone to
my webcam off and I'm just going to ride
in the other direction so that you guys
can see how the climate changes the
different sort of locations that I might
happen to posture
that's enough of my talking let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey where you are
[Music]
[Music]